بازار ولسوفا احدى الاسواق الرئيسيه في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف يخيم الظلام على
محل السوق نتيجه انقطاع الكهرباء وتصبح
الشموع واجهزه الطاقه الاحتياطيه البديله
الوحيده
المتاحات الكهرباء نقدي وقتنا في التحضير
والانتظار
مع كل هجمه الروسيه على محطات الطاقه في
اوكرانيا تزداد فترات انقطاع الكهرباء
وتقنينها في عاصمه بلاد كانت مصدرا لها
وجزء من امن الطاقه الاوربيه
الى المناطق المتضرره ويتجاوب كثيرا من
سكان العاصمه مع طلب السلطان ترشيد
استهلاكهم لتخفيف الضغط على نظام الطاقه
الاوكراني المتضرر الحرب
عمال الصيانه والمواطنون واصحاب المهن
والاعمال التجاريه كل شخص منهم يقوم بدوره
بدعم قطاع الطاقه فهذه مهمه وطنيه
لطبيب يقولوا انها عمليه جراحيه هجريه
لقلب طفل في اثناء استهداف صاروخيا ادى
الى انقطاع الطاقه عن غرفه
اما هذا المشفى فهو يسعى لتوفير ظروف جيده
للمرضى عبر ضمان استمراريه الخدمات ولو
بادنى استهلاك للطاقه
هناك تحذيرات من وزاره الصحه باننا قد
نتعرض للانقطاعات في المياه والكهرباء
لذلك اصبحت لدينا قواعدو نعمل بها في حاله
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وتدربت كوادرنا
على ذلك
لاصلاح الاضرار وايجاد حلول
مواطنها فيما لو استمر استهدافه قطاع
الطاقه في اوكرانيا
اسست السلطات الاوكرانيه في عموم البلاد
اماكن كهذه جهزتها بمصادر للطاقه غير
مرتبطه بشبكه الكهرباء العامه وذلك لتامين
الطاقه والتدفئه للسكان في حال طالت مده
انقطاع الكهرباء هي ظروف استثنائيه يعيشها
مواطنون في ظل حرب طال امدها ظروف ستبقى
في ذاكرتي من ينجون منها لوقت طويل
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره كيف